bună ziua, numele meu este Olivia Lan și sunt cercetătoare și educatoare la IBM Quantum. Acest video marchează lansarea unei
serii complet noi pe canalul de YouTube Qiskit și pe platforma noastră de învățare, numită Quantum Computing în
practică. Pe scurt, în această serie îți voi arăta cum să folosești un calculator cuantic care există chiar acum la
adevăratul său potențial. Pe internet există deja miliarde de videoclipuri despre calculatoare cuantice și potențialul lor viitor sau despre conceptele teoretice
din spatele computației cuantice, care sunt la fel de importante — vezi de exemplu „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation"
găzduit de John Watrous — dar în acest curs vom presupune că cel care învață știe deja puțin mai mult
decât în trecut și vom merge foarte departe din punct de vedere tehnic, și asta pentru că în ultimul an și la
momentul înregistrării este 2024 am văzut o schimbare, o tranziție de fază dacă vrei, într-o nouă eră a
computației. Calculatoarele cuantice se apropie în sfârșit de punctul în care pot fi utile, chiar dacă experimentarea cu
circuit-uri la scară mică și calculatoare cuantice a fost necesară pentru a educa comunitatea noastră despre cum să utilizeze aceste mașini — nimeni nu rula experimente
care să nu poată fi efectuate și pe calculatoarele clasice obișnuite. Dar începând de astăzi am intrat într-o eră a
utilității cuantice. Și ce este utilitatea, s-ar putea să te întrebi? Este diferită de Avantajul Cuantic, care poate fi înțeles ca
punctul în care calculatoarele cuantice depășesc calculatoarele clasice la o sarcină semnificativă. În schimb, utilitatea înseamnă
că pot începe să concureze unele cu altele și acesta este următorul pas natural în evoluția
tehnologică. IBM a publicat un articol care a arătat pentru prima dată anul trecut că un calculator cuantic poate fi folosit pentru a
simula un model fizic și a concura cu tehnicile clasice de simulare de ultimă generație. A depășit chiar și
încercările de forță brută și le-a oferit cercetătorilor o nouă cale pe care o pot folosi pentru cercetare. Deci de ce se întâmplă toate astea
acum? Ei bine, în ultimele luni IBM a pus la dispoziție pe scară largă procesoare cuantice de peste 100 de qubiți. Dacă ești deja
utilizator, poate ai observat că am retras multe dintre procesoarele noastre mai mici pentru a face loc acestor cipuri mai mari și am considerat că era cu adevărat
important să facem asta, deoarece unele numere de qubiți pot fi în continuare simulate clasic fără probleme, deci nu există
niciun avantaj real care să poată fi obținut folosind aceste cipuri. Totuși, la 100 de qubiți nu mai este cazul — nu pot
fi simulate clasic. Este de asemenea important de menționat că există aceste lucruri numite simulatoare, care
sunt în esență programe de calculator și pot imita un anumit comportament al sistemelor cuantice, inclusiv zgomotul. Totuși, te rog
să nu ignori faptul că am spus „imita" — simulatoarele nu sunt calculatoare cuantice. Ele nu pot produce rezultatele pe care le produc
calculatoarele cuantice la această scară, dar sunt totuși o parte importantă a fluxului nostru de testare. Deci, asta a fost un
răspuns foarte lung la întrebarea din partea de sus a acestui slide: ce este Quantum Computing practic? În acest curs te voi învăța despre cazuri de utilizare realiste cu
potențial pentru Quantum și despre cele mai bune practici pentru rularea și experimentarea pe aceste procesoare la scară mai mare
de astăzi. Deci, cui se adresează acest curs? Să începem prin a stabili câteva repere.
Chiar de la început, acest curs este pentru toți cei care doresc să dezvolte noi aplicații pentru calculatoare cuantice, vor
să știe cum să-și extindă munca actuală sau să învețe cum să folosească quantum în fluxurile lor de lucru existente. Am menționat anterior
că acest curs va fi foarte practic și nu vom discuta aspectele teoretice aproape deloc. Ne
așteptăm să vii cu o înțelegere de bază a ce este computația cuantică, dar dacă nu ești chiar acolo, nu-i problemă, te rog urmărește doar
primele câteva episoade din cursul lui John Watrous și vei fi pregătit. De asemenea, vrem să ne asigurăm că cei care urmăresc știu
că acesta nu este doar un curs pentru fizicieni sau chiar pentru informaticieni — aceste două domenii au cam
monopolizat Quantum Computing în ultimul deceniu sau cam așa ceva. Vrem să ne asigurăm că alții care lucrează cu date mari sau
simulări, cum ar fi ingineri, chimiști și oameni de știință în domeniul materialelor, știu că acest curs este și pentru ei. Pe scurt, acest
curs este îndreptat către un public larg și sperăm că ni te vei alătura pe toată durata sa. La finalizarea acestui curs
vei putea înțelege cum să creezi și să rulezi un job la scară de utilitate prin Qiskit Runtime, inclusiv întregul flux de lucru.
Vei putea înțelege principalele tipuri de mitigare a erorilor și de asemenea să înțelegi domeniile de aplicare probabile pe termen scurt. Vei putea de asemenea să
executa toți acești algoritmi în Qiskit și în final ne așteptăm să poți înțelege zgomotul și cum să-l gestionezi.
Deci, să începem. Quantum Computing este o tehnologie nouă și interesantă, aflată într-un stadiu incipient de dezvoltare, dar este doar
un capitol din povestea computației, care se întoarce cu mii de ani în urmă. Cred că este important să înțelegi acest
context deoarece face ceea ce ne dorim să realizăm aici puțin mai intuitiv, previzibil și mai puțin
SF. Din cele mai vechi timpuri noi, ca oameni, a trebuit să efectuăm calcule sau
cu alte cuvinte să procesăm informații conform anumitor reguli și constrângeri pentru a permite
comunicarea, construcția, comerțul, știința și toate celelalte aspecte ale vieților noastre. Am apelat la lumea fizică
pentru ajutor și prin descoperiri ingénioase am construit dispozitive care să ne ajute să calculăm. Demult, dispozitivele erau
făcute din lemn, os, frânghii înnodate și stocau informații și facilitau calculele mult diferit față de cum o facem
astăzi. Dispozitivele mecanice construite din pârghii, roți dințate și alte mecanisme au evoluat de la primele ceasuri astronomice la
calculatoare la sofisticate dispozitive de calcul, cum ar fi analizatoarele diferențiale care rezolvau ecuații folosind roți și
discuri rotative. Chiar și tehnologia scrisului a jucat un rol important în poveste, permițând oamenilor să efectueze
calcule pe care altfel nu le-ar putea face. Când ne gândim la calculatoare astăzi tindem să ne gândim la
calculatoare digitale electronice, dar aceasta este de fapt o tehnologie destul de recentă. Calculatoarele digitale electronice
au fost construite pentru prima dată în anii 1940. Cel mai vechi instrument cunoscut de fapt pentru calcul este abacul sumerian,
pe care experții cred că a fost inventat în Babilon în 2700–2300 î.Hr. Asta este
acum foarte mult timp, dar am ajuns să înțelegem tot mai mult despre lumea naturală — de la Arhimede la Euclid la
Einstein — nevoia noastră de mai multe resurse computaționale a explodat. Astăzi avem supercalculatoare, care sunt
practic multe calculatoare foarte puternice conectate în paralel. Ele sunt unele dintre cele mai bune instrumente pe care le are omenirea pentru
rezolvarea problemelor dificile, dar există totuși o mulțime de probleme pe care nici măcar aceste calculatoare colosale nu le vor putea niciodată
rezolva — mai multe despre asta mai târziu. Deci am stabilit că oamenii au folosit fizica și natura pentru a ne ajuta să calculăm
timp de mii de ani și pentru a ne ajuta în căutarea noastră nesfârșită de a calcula mai mult și mai mare. S-ar putea să cunoști deja
WEBVTT
Legea lui Moore. De fapt nu este chiar o lege, ci mai degrabă o observație — partea cu „legea" este puțin
ironică după părerea mea. Numărul maxim de tranzistori dintr-un circuit integrat — practic un cip de calculator —
se dublează aproximativ la fiecare 2 ani. În ultimele 5 decenii sau cam așa ceva, nu doar am observat asta, ci am profitat enorm de
ea. Cu mai mulți tranzistori putem efectua mai multe calcule mai rapid. Asta este în esență ceea ce este responsabil pentru
a face calculatoarele tot mai puternice și mai mici în timp. Totuși, există niște vești proaste: Legea lui Moore este pe moarte.
Experții nu sunt de acord cu privire la când va ajunge Legea lui Moore la sfârșitul ei inevitabil, unii spun că deja s-a întâmplat. Deși s-ar putea să nu
știm exact când vom ajunge la limita noastră, știm că este inevitabil în cele din urmă, deoarece unele componente ale tranzistoarelor
nu pot fi făcute fizic mai mici. Nu poți face un tranzistor mai mic decât un atom, de exemplu. Asta
este desigur complet nefizic — sună absurd, dar acestea sunt limitele cu care lucrăm efectiv. Deci ce
vom face? Să renunțăm și să spunem: „Asta e tot ce poate fi mai bun"? Nu — oamenii nu au făcut niciodată asta. Din fericire,
mecanica cuantică a intrat în conversație. Mecanica cuantică a fost descoperită în anii 1920 și de atunci lumea
nu a mai fost niciodată la fel, la propriu. Am putea petrece ore vorbind despre descoperirile revoluționare care au fost
făcute, dar nu acesta este focusul acestui curs. În schimb, vreau să clarific că știm că mecanica
cuantică și computația sunt deja compatibile una cu cealaltă. Descoperirile și înțelegerea naturii
pe care le-am obținut din mecanica cuantică au contribuit în parte la crearea calculatoarelor noastre moderne. Fără mecanica
cuantică nu am înțelege sau probabil nici nu am fi putut inventa hard disk-ul cu stare solidă, de
exemplu. Computația cuantică este pur și simplu următorul pas natural în această evoluție.
Dar computația nu există pur și simplu în vid — informația necesită un mediu.
Computarea informațiilor valorifică lumea fizică și o afectează de asemenea. Asta impune limitări asupra a ceea ce este posibil din punct de vedere fizic, dar
înțelegerea naturii și a limitărilor fizice este de fapt scopul fizicii ca
disciplină. Deci, într-un fel, fizica și computația au fost mereu împletite. Ralph Landauer, un om de știință în domeniul computerelor și un
cercetător IBM, a recunoscut cu zeci de ani în urmă că informația este fizică. Cu alte cuvinte, informația nu este o
entitate abstractă, ci există doar prin reprezentare fizică. Principiul lui Landauer stabilește o conexiune
între informație și legile termodinamicii, dar de fapt există multe conexiuni între fizică și
computație. Fizica clasică era tot ce puteam explora până recent, dar odată cu descoperirea mecanicii cuantice
suntem acum în pragul de a putea crea o modalitate complet nouă de a calcula. Și asta este grozav, deoarece
calculatoarele clasice pot doar aproxima ceea ce se produce de fapt în natură, iar în unele cazuri această aproximare este foarte
limitată. Asta pentru că este foarte, foarte greu să construiești mașini care urmează legile fizicii clasice pentru a
aproxima legile fizicii cuantice, iar natura nu este clasică — ea este cuantică. O analogie care te-ar putea ajuta să
înțelegi este tunelul de vânt. Dinamica fluidelor este notoriu de greu de simulat și de prezis matematic.
Chiar și ceva la fel de banal ca o mașină care conduce prin vânt — producătorii de mașini au descoperit că era cu adevărat
prea costisitor și impractical să încerce să simuleze această interacțiune fizică atunci când proiectau mașini. În schimb,
au ajuns să construiască un tunel literal care suflă vânt prin el și pur și simplu să conducă o mașină în tunel
și să vadă cum se comportă. Aceasta este analogă cu ceea ce vreau să spun atunci când zic că calculatoarele clasice aproximează slab
natura și uneori este prea costisitor să le ceri să facă asta. În loc să simuleze vântul,
cercetătorii pur și simplu îl recreează. Similar, calculatoarele cuantice nu trebuie să aproximeze legile naturii la nivel
molecular, deoarece urmează acele legi în mod intrinsec. Nu trebuie să simuleze nimic — ele emulează, și
aceleași dificultăți apar când simulăm baterii sau reacții chimice, ceea ce ne duce la următoarea noastră
secțiune: Quantum Computing — la ce este bun?
De ce am vrea să combinăm mecanica cuantică cu computația? Ei bine, există deja o mulțime
de probleme prea dificile, prea costisitoare computațional chiar și pentru supercalculatoarele noastre de ultimă generație.
Poate că acestea sunt probleme pe care numai cercetătorii le urmăresc cu mare atenție, dar impactul lor ar putea atinge toate colțurile
globului. Aceste probleme la care calculatoarele clasice se blochează sunt lucruri de care noi, ca societate, devenim din ce în ce
mai dependenți de tehnologie și ne pasă cu adevărat — cum ar fi eficiența bateriilor, modelarea financiară și
optimizarea și chiar cum să construim avioane mai bune. Deci de ce să apelăm la calculatoare cuantice? Ei bine, avem motive foarte bune
să credem că există mult potențial aici și putem deschide uși spre o nouă computație care este în prezent inaccesibilă chiar și
pentru cele mai puternice supercalculatoare. În teorie, unii algoritmi cuantici oferă avantaje față de
cei mai buni algoritmi clasici posibili pentru unele aplicații. Pentru alte aplicații există dovezi tot mai mari că chiar și
cu ceva zgomot și imperfecțiuni, calculatoarele cuantice pot fi folosite în continuare ca instrument pentru a concura cu soluțiile clasice de forță
brută. Practic, este un instrument complet nou și vrem să descoperim și mai multe lucruri interesante pe care le putem face cu el. Dar putem de asemenea
să apelăm la ideea originală a lui Feynman pentru ele, care este să le folosim pentru a înțelege fizica și natura în sine.
La urma urmei, ți-am spus deja că natura este cuantică, nu clasică, și acest domeniu este incredibil de bogat, fascinant și
interdisciplinar. Reunește fizica, informatica, procesarea informațiilor și bineînțeles domeniile specifice de aplicare care ne
ar putea interesa. Cu toate acestea, spre deosebire de calculatoarele clasice, nu toată lumea are un calculator cuantic ascuns în
buzunarul din spate. Până nu demult, dacă voiai să experimentezi cu un calculator cuantic, trebuia să construiești și să întreții
unul singur — de obicei într-un laborator trist la subsol, într-o universitate sau facilitate de cercetare. Și crede-mă, știu. Nu mai este
cazul, totuși — în 2016 IBM a pus primul procesor cuantic pe cloud. Avea doar cinci qubiți la acea vreme și
rate destul de mari de erori, dar asta a fost acum doar 8 ani și uite cât de departe am ajuns. Deci unde ne aflăm astăzi?
Există multe paralele de tras cu primele zile ale calculatorului modern. Cum am menționat, aceasta este o provocare
foarte dificilă și abia în ultimii 8 ani calculatoarele cuantice au devenit disponibile pe scară largă, altfel decât pentru
cei care lucrau într-un laborator sau facilitate de ultimă generație. Dar în acești opt ani trecuți am făcut progrese pe fiecare
WEBVTT
front: procesoarele sunt cu ordine de mărime mai mari ca număr de qubiți, gate-urile sunt mult îmbunătățite și am introdus metode
de reducere sau de mitigare a erorilor intrinseci sistemelor cuantice, chiar în timp ce avansăm pentru a crea calculatoare cuantice
tolerante la erori. Acum tu și oricine altcineva poate folosi unul dintre numeroasele procesoare IBM Quantum care sunt
găzduite în cloud — aproape toate sunt sistemele cele mai noi, recente și mai bune, cu peste 100 de
qubiți. Dar nu dimensiunea procesoarelor este singurul lucru important — aceasta este doar o singură metrică de care ne pasă, și
asta are sens, nu-i așa? Dacă avem mai mulți qubiți, evident că e mai bine, cu condiția că creșterea numărului de qubiți
nu degradează performanța. Totuși, asta nu este întotdeauna cazul. Avem nevoie de mai mulți qubiți de calitate bună care să nu interfereze
unii cu alții prin crosstalk atunci când nu vrem să o facă. Modul în care qubiții sunt conectați unii la alții este de asemenea ceva important de reținut — în
circuit-urile supraconductoare este o provocare să stabilești cum să conectezi fizic cel mai bine qubiții. O altă metrică extrem de importantă
este fidelitatea gate-ului cu doi qubiți. Gate-urile care rulează pe un singur qubit nu sunt la fel de predispuse la erori — gate-urile cu doi qubiți sunt zona mult
mai problematică și de obicei una dintre metricile de referință pe care le urmărim pentru a vedea cum se îmbunătățește performanța în
timp. Gate-urile cu doi qubiți sunt esențiale să fie corecte deoarece sunt responsabile pentru crearea entanglementului între qubiți,
care este unul dintre fenomenele fizice ce conferă calculatoarelor cuantice puterea lor. În cele din urmă, căutăm viteză și eficiență:
trebuie să ne asigurăm că timpul petrecut rulând un program pe cipul cuantic este executat cât mai rapid și eficient
posibil. Facem referire la aceste trei metrici împreună ca scară, calitate și
viteză — toate sunt vitale pentru îmbunătățirea performanței. Acum vreau să-ți arăt câteva grafice rapide care să susțină ceea ce am spus
despre cum tehnologia în sine evoluează cu adevărat destul de rapid. Numărul de qubiți în sine este cel mai ușor de
înțeles, cred, și IBM a publicat o foaie de parcurs cu locul în care sperăm să ajungem în următori câțiva ani în ceea ce privește numărul de qubiți
și dimensiunea procesorului. Pentru 2024, când filmăm acest videoclip, suntem exact pe drumul cel bun cu procesorul nostru Heron și Condor. Apoi,
calitatea: acest grafic arată rata mediană a erorii gate-ului de entanglement pentru procesoarele IBM Quantum în timp. Ține minte
că aceasta este o scară logaritmică, deci deși progresul pare vag liniar, de fapt este mult mai rapid decât pare.
În cele din urmă, avem viteza. Acest grafic arată progresul unei metrici pe care o numim CLOPS, care înseamnă circuit layer
operations per second. Crucial, CLOPS înglobează atât timpul necesar pentru a rula circuit-urile, cât și calculul clasic real și
în timp real necesar. Practic, CLOPS este o măsură a cât de rapid pot procesoarele noastre să ruleze circuit-uri specifice în
serie, acționând ca o măsură a vitezei holistice a sistemului și înglobând computația cuantică și clasică.
Chiar acum, la momentul înregistrării, IBM este singurul furnizor de cloud cuantic care oferă acces la mașini de 100
de qubiți sau mai mult. Cum am menționat câteva slide-uri în urmă, 100 de qubiți sau pe acolo este punctul unde simularea clasică
începe să eșueze complet, deci job-urile la scară largă care rulează pe aceste mașini adesea nu au un echivalent clasic — pur și simplu nu este
posibil. Există câteva nuanțe și trucuri pe care le poți folosi pentru a simula unele părți ale unui circuit și apoi alte
părți separat, dar în general știm că undeva în jurul acestui număr este locul unde calculatoarele cuantice pot începe să facă lucruri pe care calculatoarele clasice pur și simplu nu le pot. Deci
IBM a decis că oferirea accesului la aceste dispozitive mai mari era super importantă pentru comunitatea mai largă, deoarece orice
se face pe dispozitivele mai mici este simulabil clasic și deci nu poate conduce la Avantaj Cuantic. Dispozitivele de 100 de qubiți
pe care le avem acum sunt totuși defecte și sunt totuși zgomotoase, deci trebuie să fim inteligenți în modul în care rulăm job-uri și
circuit-uri pe ele. A scrie pur și simplu circuit-ul nostru și a apăsa shift+enter probabil nu va duce la nimic
spectaculos. Dar din nou, există sfaturi și trucuri pe care le putem implementa și bune practici pe care le putem urma pentru a stoarce chiar și
mai multă performanță din aceste dispozitive, ceea ce va duce sperăm la Avantaj Cuantic mai curând, chiar în timp ce continuăm
să lucrăm și să construim mașinile noastre tolerante la erori. Acest grafic arată costul simulării,
adică timpul necesar pentru a rezolva o problemă pe calculatoarele clasice și pe calculatoarele cuantice echipate cu mitigare a erorilor
și corecție a erorilor. Linia computației clasice scalează exponențial pe măsură ce complexitatea circuit-ului
crește. Pentru circuit-uri simple, jos, asta nu contează, dar evident este rău pe măsură ce complexitatea crește, deoarece asta
face costul simulării să crească foarte rapid. Mitigarea erorilor scalează mai bine, deci când complexitatea
circuit-ului crește, acolo vrem să fim. Suntem în prezent aici, cu metodele clasice și cuantice oarecum la
egalitate pentru unele aplicații, iar corecția erorilor ar putea fi cea mai de preferat și scalează cu adevărat
bine — pur și simplu nu suntem încă acolo. Între timp, vom continua să ne concentrăm pe mitigarea erorilor și să ajungem în această
zonă de utilitate cuantică cât mai curând posibil. Și prin utilizarea mai multor scheme de mitigare a erorilor, pe care le vom
studia în această serie, ne propunem să găsim domenii de aplicare care pot face uz de utilitatea cuantică foarte curând. Și asta este
cu adevărat inima acestui curs: avem aceste mașini, credem că sunt capabile să facă cercetări cu adevărat interesante,
deci cum le folosim? În această ultimă secțiune a episodului, să discutăm pe scurt domeniile de aplicare pentru
Quantum Computing practic. Există trei ramuri principale pe care credem că suntem cei mai entuziasmați să le explorăm și să găsim căi pentru utilitate
cuantică. Prima este simularea naturii — aceasta are legătură cu simularea interacțiunilor moleculare sau atomice și este cu adevărat
importantă pentru domeniile de știința materialelor și chimie. Din motivele discutate mai devreme, credem că
calculatoarele cuantice vor fi mult mai bune la asta decât calculatoarele clasice. Urmează căutarea și
optimizarea — principalul algoritm de interes aici se numește QAOA, un algoritm hibrid clasic-cuantic. QAOA folosește un
calculator clasic pentru a antrena și a găsi parametri optimi pentru un circuit cuantic și sperăm că va putea face asta
mult mai eficient decât ar putea oricare calculator singur. În cele din urmă, avem matematica și procesarea datelor cu structură: calculatoarele cuantice
sunt foarte bune la găsirea structurii în date dezordonate, unde tu sau eu sau un calculator tipic s-ar putea să nu vedem
nimic. Quantum machine learning are promisiuni în această zonă și ne propunem să folosim asta pentru sarcini cum ar fi extragerea de
caracteristici și recunoașterea tiparelor. Este cu adevărat un moment extrem de interesant pentru cei din noi care lucrăm în
domeniul Quantum Computing. Pentru prima dată în istorie putem începe să explorăm o regiune a computației care depășește
computația clasică. Cei din voi care urmăresc asta ar putea juca poate un rol similar cu pionierii timpurii ai
computației, care nu aveau nicio concepție despre ce urma să urmeze. T. J. Watson de la IBM chiar a spus în mod celebru că credea că ar putea fi
WEBVTT
o piață pentru doar două sau trei calculatoare vreodată — și cât de mult s-a înșelat! Noi
suntem toți acei pionieri timpurii ai computației, dar în acest nou domeniu al Quantum Computing. Și Quantum este adesea
contrastat cu computația clasică ca ceva distinctiv diferit de ea și adesea în competiție cu ea, dar
scopul meu pentru această prelegere introductivă a fost să te conving că, dintr-o perspectivă de ansamblu, putem vedea Quantum
Computing pur și simplu ca pe următorul capitol dintr-o lungă poveste a computației. Este în natura noastră ca oameni să căutăm noi modalități de a
calcula și de a valorifica puterea lumii naturale și de a afla ce să facem cu ea — și facem asta de
secole. Quantum Computing ne oferă un nou instrument în acest demers și depinde de noi să descoperim cum putem valorifica
puterea pe care ne-o oferă. În lecția următoare din serie vom vorbi puțin mai mult despre sistemele cu 100 de qubiți
și vom prezenta o privire de ansamblu asupra Qiskit, SDK-ul nostru de software cuantic, și despre cum să interacționezi cel mai bine cu aceste mașini acum. Mulțumesc că
ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare.